on this episode we talk about freelance
to full-time what I do when I'm
traveling and meerkat and periscope what
wins on those things you ask questions
and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
I love this idea of like color it's the
show black and white it's not cool
you're like yeah we can see they can see
this this is how it went down yeah like
this is in it 100% all right everyone
just gonna hand this off no trimming I'm
just going its until I shave it outright
it's just gonna be angry ready what's up
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 88 of the askgaryvee
show 88 a great number for me because
I'm a huge fan of al toon one of my
favorite players of all time probably my
favorite jet of all time like push comes
to shove I think I would go with Al to
number 88 of the New York Jets just a
smooth wide receiver that I enjoyed in
my heyday of my youthful Jets watching
getting excited for football I have
decided I'm going to the NFL Draft and
that gives me a solid opportunity I
would say a high probability of being
the face of the Jets draft pick because
this is in Chicago now there won't be a
lot of people wearing Jets jerseys like
normally in New York I and AJ will be
doing that and so look for me on NFL
Network and espn.com on draft day
because I fully expect to make
appearance and we'll see how I react to
the sixth pick in the draft
um excited about the show India was sick
yesterday she's feeling slightly better
I appreciate the hustle of working
through that and not being soft Indian
staying at home another day a little bit
of switcheroo Stefan showed the Iraq the
Iraq not behind the camera is there's a
training in process in case you ever got
sick yes I like that let's get into the
show John Luke asks this question really
got me thinking when do you shift from
high
a freelancer to hiring someone for
full-time jean-luc easy question it's
just easy there's really a couple of
scenarios number one the moment you fall
in love with them and you say you should
join my team full-time because we are
gonna be great together this will bring
value to my business number two when you
have a necessity when you when your
business is growing whether it's a new
client or you're selling more of your
stuff that they're producing for or
whatever it may be your business has
grown and now you have a tested employee
that goes to full time there's a third
scenario when the freelancer is so
infatuated in love with your business
that they're pushing aggressively to
join the team it may not be practical
you may not be able to fully afford it
but your intuition tells you that
long-term you know nine months from now
the ROI will start kicking in and I want
to reward this person's passion around
me so I'm willing to make a little less
money in the short term for that
relationship and that stickiness of the
long game those tend to be the scenarios
when you make the shift jean-luc Zack
asks what's your travel schedule like to
and from the office car train uber walk
and how do you spend that time Travis
second I just thought Travis because of
uber probably Zack Zack I I am I live on
the Upper East Side our office on 24th
and park so on the east side the
straight sheet down from from Park
Avenue that is ninety percent of the
time I move in the morning then I
obviously travel a lot so a lot of time
it's to JFK or things of that nature
it's always in in uber or black car or
taxi so it's it's it's usually in a car
I'm sitting in the back seat belt on
safety first what I don't even know why
I did hashtag there 61st what I call my
mom call Brandon check my email check my
Twitter
looks on my Instagram that's really what
music me usually doing it's usually mom
or Brandon Brandon who runs Wine Library
to catch up on the day to strategize a
little bit checking email checking
Twitter looking through Instagram a
little bit now right now checking my
fantasy baseball team and the news
around fantasy baseball and then moments
in time right where where check my
nuzzle for news and you know it about
maybe seven or eight days I'll start
checking the NFL Draft news that will go
away then I'll get into training camp
news but for the most part I'm fully in
mom Brandon once you know sprinkle in my
sister later a little bit but my sister
and dad come more ad hoc during the day
that's kind of how I do it Brian asks
Gary did you catch the wired story on
Walt Disney World's billion-dollar magic
band how do you see this space evolving
what do you think about the necessity
for these online/offline
bridge technologies Brian I mean you
know the answer right like this is an
interesting question because this is
inevitable smart technology is gonna eat
up the world everything the world will
be smart all of it all of it your shirt
your pants your underwear your sneakers
your socks the wearables it's all coming
over the next 10 20 30 years it allows
things that are physical to go so much
further in the digital world the
layering that and and the ammo that this
gives Disney and that upfront investment
is extraordinary
the recall the content pushing out the
unlocking virtual things all of a sudden
now they can change the flow of the park
one of the things I'm fascinated by as a
retailer and the thing that I don't
think a lot of people think about is
efficiencies in an airport or an
amusement park or a retail store where
you know there's congested area around
Splash Mountain but you know there's
other parts of the park where people
aren't going well now imagine slapping
some technology on a rock all the way in
left field around the haunted house
where that's the last piece of the band
touching for you to unlock the thing now
you're moving people there less
lines more less lines in front of food
all of a sudden people buying an extra
fourth of a hotdog on average got it
these are really fascinating business
dynamics that I think will play out for
Disney specifically as for the rest of
the space hey man I mean the Apple watch
is going to be a game-changer for one
whether it's successful or not from what
I've read and I have won a pre-order
this buzzing on your body which is
saving you time from looking at your
phone you know what I think about time
is super fascinating it's gonna start if
it clicks the way the smartphone did
you'll start having people at scale with
it it's gonna be the next smart thing
that kind of happened the watch it's
just all coming you're properly looking
at it for your business everybody should
be looking at it for their business if
they produce stuff and and it's a space
that I'm spending a lot of time looking
at vayner/rse for our investments
because it's clearly in the way that
social networks and the maturity of the
internet felt right to me in two
thousand five six and seven wearable
smart technology being infiltrated into
everything we do this cup from from you
know India telling India that the coffee
is getting coffee the coffee is getting
cold and drink up kiddo it's fascinating
it's all fascinating a smart beard is
coming soon trim your trim me trim your
[ __ ] mother Jane asks many of your jabs
and right hooks reach your b2c audience
wine and books for example but how does
it impact b2b Jane my right hooks are
not made for b2b so you'll never see me
tweet hey if you have a business I want
your business at vaynermedia it's just
not feasible for me but my jabs do my
content where I talk about my thought
leadership or my my my ambition to be a
thought leader or my hope that I my
thought leader you know the more I say
things that are right you know somebody
watching or listening right now to
askgaryvee episode 88 I say something
about smart technology that makes them
say yeah
they need that for their business hey
Gary clearly seems to be paying
attention to this maybe I should talk to
Bainer about doing some activations
around it we have clearly benefited as
an agency from my outward content as a
gateway drug to RFPs or out-and-out
handed the business so vaynermedia is
clearly benefited from all of this and
you know this is something I'm very
passionate about for all of you that are
watching and listening it's super
important to me for you to realize that
you're always one great piece of content
away from having your life change like
let's just understand what I mean by
this it's no different than being an
artist with a song everybody like
everybody you know started off not being
known and then had a song that changed
their life every investor you've heard
of that is done well and made lots of
money had a an investment Twitter that
changed their lives content though not
to the level of Madonna or Chris Sacca
right content has the potential to
change your life so if you love
something music photography running
culture diet culture museum culture like
whatever you love you have to understand
by talking to the world even if one
person's listening all you need is that
one person to share it the pipes of
social network get into motion this is
why I love medium medium will handpick
content from nobodies not big followers
just a good piece of content and that
becomes again your one piece of content
away from what you want to happen
happening now here's the problem most of
you are not good enough to make that
content and I and I get it like that was
rough and I'm like and I apologize but
talent matters right like like baseball
players that get discovered in Japan
that come over to us make last money
they had to be good enough to be
discovered you know the quality of the
content you put out matters like you
can't just be like museums are nice
that's not gonna lead to you being the
CEO of a museum
do you understand you've got to be right
when I go out and put out content that
says Instagram is gonna get bought by
Facebook and then everybody says I'm an
idiot and then it happens I'm not an
idiot
get it so you know the things the
pressure I put them on myself to answer
these five questions on every episode is
these are historic we're gonna look back
at that and if I'm like wearable
technologies have no chance it's a fad
and then it happened
idiot that wasn't my piece of content
that took me to the next level it was a
piece of content that took me a step
back so recognize that we have the
opportunity to win this game recognize
the quality of what we say what we
produce how we put it out there is the
variable to that upside John asks which
industries do you think will leverage
meerkat the best who is their target
user what do you think Gary
so John throwing periscope in there as
well
meerkat and periscope will be leveraged
by a lot of people but I actually think
retail man
I think Huey see like opportunities on
meerkat like like I we're meter counting
right now how many people on two hundred
275 you know I could schedule a meerkat
and I'm planning on doing this by the
way in a couple of months maybe a couple
weeks where I'm gonna say from 6:00 p.m.
to 9:00 p.m. Eastern I'm gonna do a QVC
like wine show where I'm just gonna sit
here and taste wine and somebody
indie-rock on the other ends gonna be
like this person that's this this person
that is like we're literally gonna do a
live QVC I think retail selling stuff on
live is very real to me I'm a big
believer in it imagine a mere canning
then I'm tweeting or facebooking links
to the things I'm talking about people
are interacting sharing links it's just
super fascinating to me so my big bet is
that retail will be able to take big
advantages of it because it's the people
that can really take advantage of what
this is replicating the reason I do well
with businesses I realize nothing really
changes things just evolve meaning
meerkat and periscope are just live
television
what does well QVC what else does well
entertainment
so let me somebody can start on that too
damaging what else as well sports
so I could see a local minor league
baseball team or you know like there's
just a sports does well right so like
you could start a frisbee league that
you get people into by watching it and
then sponsors will pay you back yard
basketball leagues you know the fighting
that we still hardcore fighting that you
see on YouTube that gets me into the
rabid I mean I waste no time on anything
and even I once in a while get suckered
into like street fighting on YouTube
because the knockout is just so intense
you know I would watch that on meerkat I
would watch that a meerkat right now
like if two dudes want to raise their
hand and fight two chicks I mean you
know whatever fight I'll watch that [ __ ]
off without pay $2.99 to watch it live
so I think that anything that's live on
television periscope and meerkat have
the chance to play in that's where I see
the upside that's in oh great
that was a good show sound show solid
answers that's good question of the day
I want to break it up into two parts
one would you televise anything on
meerkat and periscope consistently and
two how much time in a 24 hour day would
you allocate to watching something live
on one of those platforms fascinating
stuff really really interesting by the
way on the record even though I'm a big
investor of meerkat on the record still
convinced in my body at this moment
right now that live-streaming is a very
challenging sector and you know in the
bait of who's gonna win between meerkat
and periscope and I know wrote about
this but I must say it again for the
show you know neither feels equally as
possible as one or the other and I still
think that damn ghosts in LA snapchat is
a wild card in this entire game so you
keep asking questions I will keep
answering them
with my beard
people focus on too many small details
way too many people just remember going
to spend the next 30 40 years of their
lives trying to check the boxes other
things that they're not as good at and
that you're gonna waste a lot of time
and news